how beautiful is this is an experiment
in quantum mechanics called the double
slit experiment but I really didn't
expect to see this when I did it myself
and seeing this changed my mind on an
important question in physics
what is light
but before all that here's a simple
experiment that you can do all you'll
need is a laser pointer and a strand of
hair
so if I just take this laser and I shine
it at this whiteboard here you can see
that you just get a DOT but what do you
reckon will happen if I put this hair in
the way you might expect the dot to get
split into two dots or for there to be a
dark line through the dot or nothing at
all to happen since the hair is so small
but let me show you what actually
happens in the dark because it looks
really impressive
surprising right and it's nothing to do
with the hair itself you can do the
exact same experiment with anything thin
this is a variation on the double slit
experiment which is an experiment that's
so important you learn about it or
pretty much day one of any Quantum 101
class the normal way to do the
experiment is to shine a light on two
very narrow slits then the light that
goes through goes through the left or to
the right this variation is pretty much
the same the light goes through one way
or the other but besides being easier to
do this way the other Advantage is the
pattern you get you can see that they
both have the same sort of flavor but
they're different for example the dashes
of light for the hair version are all
evenly spaced and get lighter as we go
but the dots of the double slit are much
more patchy that's because of something
called single slit interference which is
basically a distraction in this scenario
so yeah I kind of prefer the hair
version plus check this out
I'm using this smoke in a can stuff to
see the actual beam but look really
closely at the beam
and you can actually see where the hair
splits the light into two how crazy is
that and looking at this I think it's
really hard to understand why you get
the crazy double slit pattern when it
seems like obviously you should just get
a DOT with a line through it
so I've done my PhD in Quantum stuff and
I thought I understood the theory of
this experiment really well and so my
plan was just to explain it to you in a
cute little video about how to do the
experiment at home instead I got sucked
into an odyssey for the last few months
where I did all kinds of variations on
the experiment and I ended up like
questioning pretty much everything I
thought I knew about light it turns out
this experiment is just way more
interesting than I thought there's
always been this debate in physics about
whether light is made out of a stream of
particles or like some sort of
excitation like a wave the double slit
experiment was meant to definitively
prove that light is a wave except later
experiments seem to show that light has
particle-like properties as well
I used to hate this whole wave particle
thing because light is clearly neither a
great analogy I heard for it is that
light is like a platypus it doesn't make
sense to say that it's both a duck and a
beaver at the same time because it is
its own thing but actually doing this
experiment finally made me see the value
in having good analogies to help you
think about light and in particular it
really sold me on thinking about light
in terms of waves it also made me see
how misleading the particle analogy can
be if you're not super careful about it
I think many of us imagine photons which
are what physicists now called particles
of light in a similar way to how Newton
thought of light particles but the
double slit experiment shows why
Newton's particle view is definitely
wrong you should imagine light in the
same way we now think of water inside
it's just made of a stream of light
particles in the same way that water is
made out of water particles I'm going to
call these particles that Newton thought
light was made out of localized
particles because at every point in time
they're just in one spot in space
they're not in multiple places or very
spread out or anything like that
if you turn down the laser enough Newton
would have expected that light comes out
in these individual particles instead
people like Thomas Young imagine light
coming out as some sort of wave
in this case no matter how much you turn
down the laser the light would still be
a wave it would just be less and less
wavy
the light travels forward not in lines
but as peaks of a wave progressing
forward
in the case of just turning on a
flashlight both Newton's picture and
Thomas Young's wave picture make exactly
the same predictions but Newton's view
just feels bright like you have these
particles just traveling in straight
lines which is so much simpler than this
strange abstract wave thing which is why
it's so tempting to think of light this
way in fact I've seen pictures just like
this one to illustrate photons exiting a
light source in many reputable textbooks
and I get why that's kind of how I
imagine photons too so how did Thomas
Young go about disproving it he needed
to find an experiment that could only be
explained with waves and not with
Newton's particles well one unique thing
that waves do is that they Bend and
spread out you may have seen this before
but for me at least it was kind of
surprising let me show you with this
high-tech Ripple tank I made here
you can see that when I Bob this plastic
in the water it makes fairly straight
waves but what do you expect will happen
when I put this obstruction in the way
I would have guessed that the bit of the
wave that makes it past just goes
straight ahead and that's what the
majority of the wave does do but the
rest of it bends and spreads out
you can see that in action here but why
does it happen I don't really know I
would love to understand it better and
make a video about it but until then you
can see that this is something waves
actually do they spread out when they
meet an obstacle that definitely feels a
lot different from how I'd expect
particles to behave so why don't we do a
similar experiment with light and see
what happens will light Bend and spread
out or will it go straight
I'm going to use a piece of paper as the
obstruction to find out
and there you go the laser light does
actually spread out Case Closed light is
a wave right well maybe we should give
Newton a chance to rebut this I guess he
could try and explain this with
particles perhaps the particles are
colliding into the paper and then
ricocheting and that's why they spread
out like this okay fine maybe you can
explain that but there is another way
phenomenon that particles definitely
can't mimic and that's canceling out one
way to think of the last experiment is
that it's like we took the hair
experiment and then just blocked One
path
we found that at least some of the light
ends up in all of these places including
in this spot
if we had blocked the right path instead
we'd have gotten a very similar result
and again notice that at least some of
the light falls on this spot
now let's open both paths simultaneously
and the light just disappears from this
spot
there is no way for Newton to explain
this think about it if you believe in
the kind of particles that Newton did
then when just the left path is open
some of your particles will reach that
spot and when the right path is open
some of your particles will reach that
spot but when both of them are open it's
like the particles from the right side
and the particles from the left side
just happen to cancel each other out in
this spot which just doesn't make sense
but why not why can't you just have the
particles cancel well because in this
spot they need to cancel but just a
little bit over the particles coming
from the left and from the right should
happily coincide it's like they
sometimes choose to cancel and sometimes
they choose not to so I'm sorry Newton
but particles like yours really aren't
good enough to explain how you could
ever get canceling but then how do waves
manage to explain the double slit
experiment let's imagine a wave is
coming out of the laser on the right
side the wave encounters the hair and
because it's an obstacle it bends and it
spreads out like we discussed before
on the other side the exact same thing
happens
back in our wave pool the black
obstruction in the middle now represents
the hair and as you can see the waves on
either side do spread out and they
overlap but something very surprising is
happening in that overlap and you can't
really make it out in this Precision
setup but it's going to be a lot more
clear in the animation
where are all these lines coming from
to understand what's going on imagine
you're on a boat in this spot then the
wave coming from the left will have its
peak reach you at exactly the same time
as the wave coming from the right
together they tend to push you up even
higher the troughs also meet you at the
same time so this spot is just really
choppy but if we instead move our boat
to here then the peak of the right wave
hits exactly when the trough of the left
wave hits you the peak tries to move you
upward while the trough tries to pull
you down and so in the end they cancel
out and the boat doesn't really move up
or down so this spot is surprisingly
calm there are these choppy and calm
spots all over and if you map them out
then you get these lines
what's this got to do with the double
slit experiment well look at the waves
across the wall you have these
alternating parts of choppiness and
calmness that lines up suspiciously well
with the pattern of the double slit
where you have alternating spots of
light and dark Thomas Young's hypothesis
was when there's this waving there's
light
and when the waves cancel out and so
there's no waving there is no light in
other words the amount of light produced
in its spot is proportional to the
amount of weaving
you know I've given this explanation to
students for years but I've never taken
the whole wave picture very seriously
like yes I knew that to make the right
prediction for the double slit you would
have to use waves in your calculation
but I thought they were just that you
know like just calculation tools I
didn't think that they were real I mean
like literally in quantum mechanics the
waves are complex valued so instead in
my head you know I thought of the light
as a particle when it exited the laser
and then a particle again when it got
measured at the wall but in between it
just seemed like there's nothing you
could really say about the light besides
a bunch of equations
but this next experiment is what changed
my mind and made me finally feel that
the waves are actually real
so I've been playing with this for a
while and I haven't been able to get
this thought out of my mind
there's a beam
here
that leads to this middle dot that's
clearly where the light from that for
that dot is coming from right but what
about all these other dots
like surely that light is coming from
somewhere as well and I it feels like
you can always Trace back exactly where
that light's from for this one if I
follow it
I can go all the way back
and same for these as well
so it feels like there should be beams
kind of coming
out here
I got obsessed with this idea that you
should be able to see these beams of
light if you just use the right method I
tried everything like doing the
experiment of midnight for maximum
contrast and then filling a box with
smoke then I tried filling a tub with
water vapor I even tried submerging my
laser into agar nothing in the end I
caved and I bought a smoke machine from
a DJ shop and I also decided to use the
proper double slit so that the little
bands are more intense and it worked I
would love if you actually tried this
experiment yourself because it's so easy
to do but I need to warn you about
something laser pointers are way less
safe than you probably think I bought a
bunch of lasers from Amazon that all
claim to be under five milliwatts
anything over that limit can permanently
burn a hole in your retina so let's
compare these cheap lasers with a proper
five milliwatt laser to see if they're
safe
as you can see this green one is
definitely not okay in general Green
Lasers are something I really don't
recommend you buy from Amazon red laser
pointers are better in my experience
especially little ones like this that
are advertised as like keychains or cat
toys rather than like this type but yeah
if you're going to be using a laser for
presenting or experiments or playing
with your cat just make sure it isn't
one that's going to burn someone's eyes
out anyway it was worth buying the smoke
machine
this experiment looks just magical in
real life and all I've done to capture
it is use my phone nothing fancy I set
the double slit up a few meters away and
blocked all the lights and turned on the
smoke machine and all of these beams
suddenly became visible
here you can see that there are beams of
light going to all of the dots of the
double slit pattern but to see it even
more clearly let's turn around and look
toward the laser
and now so many beams become visible
the double slit doesn't split the light
up into two beams it splits the light
into many many beams
so why was this experiment such a
revelation for me well it felt like I
was actually seeing the light be a wave
for a first time let me show you what I
mean with this laser here you can see
the narrow beam of the laser but if I
put this paper in the way a wave should
spread out
and yeah that's exactly what the laser
does but to see it more clearly let's
add some smoke
this looks almost unreal the laser beam
is spread out but only in this one plane
just like we'd predict for a wave if I
remove the paper and put in the double
slit instead you can see the two sides
of the beam interfere and cancel out
again just like a wave should
seeing this was the first time that I
actually felt in my gut that light is
somehow wave-like up until now I just
thought that the waves of quantum
mechanics were abstract and they're not
they're actually there and you can see
pretty clear evidence of them and so
since then I've started taking the whole
wave picture much more seriously
on the other hand I've become more
cautious about imagining light as
particles photons are much more nuanced
clearly than I thought before and I want
to try and do experiments with them as
well to understand how I should be
thinking of them which is why Quantum
experiments at home is gonna be a series
I hope you have lots of questions left
about light and if you do please leave
them in the comments and we'll try and
sort them out together in future
episodes
see you then